welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
what if episode three in which the
avengers get a taste of another kind of
vengeance that ends up popping the hulk
like a zit
boom you looking for this
i'm gonna go back through this episode
frame by frame for all the easter eggs
and hidden animation details that you
might have overlooked we open on monday
this episode uses days of the week to
structure its five acts because this is
what's known in the marvel timeline as
furies big week in which the events of
iron man 2 hulk and thor all take place
at the same time based off of some
newsreel footage that we saw at the end
of iron man 2 and a lion in iron man 2
about coulson headed off to new mexico
fury drives with natasha romanov there
was an idea
to bring together a group of remarkable
people to see if they could become
something more i know i've heard the
speech samuel l jackson is back as fury
natasha is actually voiced by lake bell
this is of course his fury's big speech
that he uses to rally cap and tony after
coulson's death in the 2012 avengers
film there was an idea to bring together
a group of remarkable people see if they
could become something more see if they
could work together when we needed them
to to fight the battles that we never
could natasha's pointed finger lines up
perfectly with the reflection of tony
sitting in the donut this shop is
randy's donuts in los angeles but the
framing of most of the shots here kind
of frames out the randy's including the
windows and the interior shots though as
they pull up in the car you can see the
ra at the top of the donut there all of
the framing and music and dialogue here
is mirrored from iron man 2. sir
i'm gonna have to ask you to exit the
donut though in the movie on the
sidewalk was 3 16 for john 3 16. for god
so loved the world that he gave his one
and only son that whoever believes in
him shall not perish but have eternal
life which as a detail in iron man 2 i
always liked as a reflection of that
movie's father and son themes with
howard stark offering his only son tony
as this sacrificial savior of humanity
but 316 does not appear here maybe as a
way of showing that in this universe
tony stark never gets the chance to be
that savior as he does in the movie tony
says i told you i don't want to join
your super secret boy band now tony is
voiced here not by robert downey jr but
by mick wingert who has actually voiced
tony stark in a number of marvel
animated titles he sounds almost exactly
like robert downey jr fury points to the
palladium poisoning on tony's neck and
he says you become a problem a problem i
have to deal with contrary to your
belief you are not the center of my
universe now this line in the movie
flows directly into a reference to the
events in thor you have become a problem
a problem i have to deal with contrary
to your belief you are not the center of
my universe i have bigger problems than
you in the southwest region to deal with
but fury here never gets to that because
natasha's lithium dioxide injection
causes an adverse reaction that kills
tony now natasha in the movie said it's
not a cure just to base the symptoms
which she says here but draws out the
line as she realizes tony is dying it's
not a cure
it just
abates the symptoms stuck
you okay fury looks down at tony in
shock and he cross dissolves into the
watcher the slideshow takes us through
memorable shots from fury's big week in
the movies tony's hiding his poisoning
and fighting whiplash monaco bruce
banner emerging from some hulk wreckage
though notice they changed banner's
appearance to look more like mark
ruffalo who was recast as the character
after ed norton played him in the 2008
incredible hulk film just kind of
erasing ed noren's whole appearance from
the cinematic universe aren't we and
then some images from the battle of new
york a couple years after that clint and
natasha fighting chitari hulk smashing
loki and the avengers lining up then we
catch up with agent bill coulson clark
gregg returning to voice in this episode
he finds mjolnir in the same framing
from that iron man 2 post-credits scene
meanwhile at the project pegasus base
the shield strike unit detains natasha i
may not have been a fan of tony stark
but i didn't kill him save your spin for
pierce i want you in new york first
thing for questioning frank grillo
returns to voice brock rumlow here
future crossbones he references pierce
aka world security council secretary
alexander pierce robert redford's
character from captain america winter
soldier and avengers end game and on the
right of that unit is rollins callum
mulvey's character from rumlow's group
just like how steve rogers takes down
this same unit in a confined space in
captain america winter soldier natasha
does the same as she repeatedly jabs a
guy in the jaw you can see little
dribbles of spit flying out and there's
just some really fun animation direction
on natasha's combat staying on her use
of her right leg first to knee a guy
then without stepping down to kick a guy
behind her then keeping the leg up
hooking over to another guy and then
bringing that heel back on the guy
behind her and then only now after
changing her balance she finishes with a
simultaneous punch kick rumlow realizes
she's escaped oh
come on
yeah the animation on the mouth swallow
characters talk in the show is a little
non-specific so in this case it looks
like rumblo is about to make the f
consonant like
and then back at the mule near site in
puente antiguo new mexico a term in
spanish translates to ancient bridge an
easter egg that was in thor referencing
this being a connection point to the
ancient bifrost bridge hawkeye clint
barton voiced by jeremy renner says also
no one can lift it not even jackson he
does crossfit yeah agent jackson was
actually one of the shield agents at
this site in a thor film played by jamie
mcshane
lancy jackson west side perimeter go
check it out now to be clear this fury
and hawkeye are not the same universe
ones who ended episode 1 when captain
carter arrived through the portal in
that reality steve rogers never went
down into the ice with that shield
whereas that was his fate in this
universe as we learned in the final
scene coulson thinks thor's hot he's a
caucasian male mid-20s with
really great hair excuse me it's an
accurate description sir he's gorgeous
and as thor struts toward mjolnir he
tosses his wet hair similar to how chris
hemsworth did during these scenes in the
movie the animators also gave thor super
blonde eyebrows with no dark borderlines
to outline them as a way of evoking
hemslear's weirdly bleached eyebrows in
that movie glad they stopped doing that
in the mcu now in the film it was colson
who ordered hawkeye to hold fury wasn't
actually here because coulson wanted to
see if thor could lift the hammer now it
is fury but before thor gets the chance
clint slips and lets the arrow fly and
the bolt of lightning ironically the
force of nature that should have
empowered the god of thunder fury and
coulson appreciate thor's corpse
wow
even while rotting he smells like
lavender really
similar to how the guardians of the
galaxy sniffed and drooled over his
incapacitated body in an infinity war
[Music]
this is a man
a handsome
muscular man on to culver university in
virginia the setting of the battle in
the 2008 hulk movie betty ross is voiced
by stephanie penicello and she's wearing
the same clothes betty wears in that
movie including her mother's necklace
that in the movie she pawns and banner
later returns to her betty helps natasha
realize that nanotech interfered with
the syringe a clue of course pointing to
pymtech and then on the table natasha
sees a hat in jacket versus stanley's
pizza parlor that was a restaurant in
the movie where banner works run by
stanley lieber his name a nod to stan
lee and he's played by actor paul soules
who voiced bruce banner in the 60s
animated series the marvel superheroes
on fury's screen during the call are
files of all the avengers candidates
clint barton thor tony stark on the left
bruce banner hulk and above him a female
i thought was natasha but that's
actually the same file photo of janet
van dyne that later appears on the
shield servers so the answer to fury's
mystery was right there in front of him
the whole time the death slash
disappearance of his og avenger that led
to her daughter working for shield and
when she died her father hank pym losing
it bruce banner emerges from the closet
voiced by mark ruffalo
no need for violence agent romanov
that's probably not gonna work out for
anyone and the watcher watches colson
drive out to the new mexico site where
an asgardian army led by loki arrives
they look like they're from earth maybe
middle earth
colson naturally isn't a lord of the
rings loki voiced by tom hiddleston of
course orders you would do best to kneel
before a god just like he ordered the
germans to nail
and when he tried to force the
mongolians to kneel to him in loki
episode 1 and he introduces himself i am
loki crown prince of asgard the rightful
king of yortun
yotenheim and
god of
mischief yeah crowned king of asgard but
rightful king of jotunheim this would
mean that had thor died in the first
thor film loki would have been
unchallenged in seizing the throne
though at this point in the narrative he
has not yet taken jotunheim odin's
probably still in his odin's sleep which
lady siff voiced by jamie alexander
seems to indicate he's not wrong the all
father would want us to listen also
among loki's ranks are the warriors
three vulstag fandral and hogan and the
far background the asgardian destroyer
armor which fury chats with later loki
uses the casket of ancient winters to
freeze fury's forces he actually found
this in odin's vault in the thor film in
the scene where odin confirmed to him
his frost giant lineage and loki later
used this against heimdall during his
coup of asgard but real quick thanks to
our sponsor the walking dead no man's
land is the official mobile game for
amc's the walking dead and it's
available for free on ios and android no
man's land is not a generic tapping game
it's a tactical turn-based strategy game
where each move you make needs to be
thought out in order to take down and
escape the walkers it's got thousands of
hours of content and lots of different
game modes the game has an active and
engaged community for players to join
the 11th and final season the walking
dead just premiered and with it comes
new in-game missions new weapons new
playable characters and exciting live
events that are directly linked to each
new episode available the day after each
episode premieres on tv there's a new
game mode the last stand in which
players fight endless waves of walkers
the walking dead no man's land is free
to download using my link in the
description and when you use the promo
code new rockstars you can get a free
musket and free gas for 24 hours so
download now using my link or by
scanning the qr code on screen bruce and
natasha appear on the campus crosswalk
bridge where banner is cornered in the
movie general thaddeus ross appears
voiced by mike mcgill and banner turns
into the hulk and natasha dives out
sticking her famous landing pose that
elena bulova made fun of her for in
black widow now i like how this version
of the hulk uses design elements from
both the 2008 ed norton film like the
longer shaggier hair but also the 2012
ruffalo redesign like the humanistic
expressions in the face also chest hair
and i honestly think they kept those
sympathetic ruffle features to make this
even more shocking
ah god now it is largely so disturbing
because of hulk's confused facial
expressions as he suffocates his own
inflating flesh and i hate to do this
but if you show a hoax inflation frame
by frame his neck and cheeks cram into
his traps in his chest and the explosion
points burst out from the creases
between his muscles as they squeeze
together now the explosion is green
smoke i assume because disney might have
felt uneasy with fluids or wet tissue or
bone or guts but you could also see this
as a kind of blood mist as hank pym's
tech vaporizes him from the inside out
yeah this frame by frame stuff ain't as
fun when the imagery ain't so disney now
natasha calls colson to get his password
to log into the shield server hashtag
steve steve steve i heart steve
704. wow good one colson yes reminder of
coulson's fan crush on steve rogers with
0704 being steve's birthday of july 4.
natasha brings up files on phil coulson
nick fury janet van dyne maria hill and
alexander pierce but janet is listed as
deceased and then over in the left
corner you can see her file was accessed
recently along with those other active
members at 11 23 the day before and then
the camera cuts back to natasha as she
realizes who accessed this quote a woman
who died two years ago referring to
janet's daughter of hope
it's all about hope and fury listens to
this voicemail in isabella's diner the
town eatery in the 2011 thor film
coulson quotes the avengers initiative
speech 2 fury and he shows him the memo
that was written by fury perhaps part of
the paperwork that fury originally
drafted in that final scene of captain
marvel and that could be why fury now
retrieves the captain marvel pager that
was boosted with cree tech that he and
danvers agreed that they would use to
summon her at the end of the captain
marvel film and of course he later used
in the infinity war post-credits scene
the watcher also oversees this misty
cemetery in san francisco now in
avengers end game a memorial was set up
overlooking the golden gate bridge on
chrissy field on the city side of the
bay but in this shot the city is in the
background meaning this cemetery would
be on the other side of the bridge in
marin county fury or who we think is
fury approaches the grave of hope van
dyne
if it isn't hank pym yeah we hear a
little insect buzz there for hank pym in
his yellowjacket armor which natasha
might have been able to hear ever so
softly in the library earlier
michael douglas returns to boyce pym the
balls you have to come here
and stand over her grave and yeah pym
was wearing the yellow jacket suit in
the comics hank pym was the first to
suit up as yellowjacket after he left
the ant-man mantle not really a good guy
in the 80s comics now of course fury is
very much out of character i doubt she'd
mind considering she's dead her mother
was an agent i don't give a damn about
any of them yes this irreverence comes
from him actually being loki disguises
fury which is why the only time his tone
shifts to sirius is when he asks about
thor and what a thor prince of asgard
now fury responds agent hope van dyne
was killed on a mission outside odessa
ukraine odessa now as i went into an
inside marvel odessa could refer to that
shield mission that natasha romanov went
on where she ran into the winter soldier
five years ago i was escorting a nuclear
engineer out of iran somebody shot out
my tires near odessa but the winter
soldier was there so he shot him
straight through me but in this reality
hope van dyne could have been fury's
go-to avenger to go on such missions
before he would take his big swings on
natasha romanov but whereas natasha
survived the winter soldier's bullet
pope did not hank reveals it was he and
natasha's syringe he who loosened
clint's fingers to release the arrow in
a moment evoking when scott lang clung
to hawkeye's arrow in civil war it was
hank pym who buzzed into clint's ear and
mushed up his brain
and it was hank pym who threw a resizing
disc like the ones we've seen ant-man
use on hulk's heart which caused it to
enlarge separate from the rest of his
body and i guess pump out blood at a
faster rate than his other glands and
muscles could adjust for what a way to
go i guess since hulk grows at a rate
proportional to his anger something that
would be linked to his heart rate i
guess this could happen it's just
upsetting that hank pym would know to do
this because hulk is supposed to be
invulnerable even to internal
projectiles like banner in avengers says
that he put a gun in his mouth and hulk
spit out the bullet but i guess that
doesn't apply to magical pym tech
applied to internal organs using hulk's
own growth powers against him between
this and pimp articles having time
travel capabilities anyone with pymtek
is potentially the deadliest killer in
the mcu and apparently this does answer
the age-old question of what would
happen if ant-man flew up inside thanos
booty hole and decided to enlarge
fury definitely swats away hank he
blocks his blows he evades his lasers
and he uses duplication projection of
course revealing himself as the god of
mischief and i like how the reveal uses
this mix of samuel l jackson's laughter
with tom hiddleston's laughter because
nick fury would not be laughing
maniacally in this moment loki would
[Laughter]
it's just kind of fun like seeing chris
evans do an impression of loki do an
impression of him loki and a not at all
surprising twist takes over the planet
marches into the u.n and makes his big
speech to the world it's the unspoken
truth of humanity that you crave
subjugations the bright fear of freedom
hobbles you diminishes your life's joy
of course this is loki's speech to the
germans from avengers it's the unspoken
truth of humanity
that you crave subjugation
the bright lure of freedom diminishes
your life's joy actually in times square
the chiron over there on the left reads
green explosion at culver yeah if that's
what you want to call it there's also a
coffee tree cafe billboards for
bulgarian olympia the musical but then
on the far right an ad for pinko doce
that was the juice from the 2008 hulk
film that banner bled into the bottling
plant and got random people sick
including stan lee fury and coulson look
over the row of coffins containing the
avengers remains i don't know what you
put in there for hulk but each are
draped with their logo iron man's helmet
thor's hammer hawkeye's shield and zero
hulk's fist and black widow's hourglass
but there's only five because there is
one avenger left still frozen in ice and
fury wipes away that frost from cap's
shield welcome back captain
so where's the fight yes captain
marvel's glow reflects on fury's face
similar to the way it did on tony
stark's face when she rescued him in
in-game carol here is voiced by
alexandra daniels and she's wearing the
red on blue suit that she wore at the
end of captain marvel as opposed to the
one with the gold trim that she wore
when she met with the avengers at the
start of end game or the blue topped one
on the other side of the blip in in-game
so whenever her first costume change
occurred it would have happened closer
to the modern era i would be curious to
see a new avengers lineup co-captained
by steve rogers and carol danvers
especially for what light this could
shed on carol's mystery backstory with
monica rambo something alluded to a few
times in one division and expected to be
explored in the marvels support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options including our marvel what if
limited edition shirt i love this over
at newrockstarsmerch.com
and a reminder that the walking dead no
man's land is free to download using my
link in the description and when you use
promo code new rockstars you can get a
free musket and free gas for 24 hours
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you